[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم سادت حاله من التفاؤل الحذر
الاوساط الامريكيه والايرانيه بعد لقاء
نيويورك بين وزيري خارجيه البلدين فهناك
من اعتبره خطوه نحو تقارب منتظر وهناك
اخرون قللوا من قدرته على تجاوز خلافات
امتدت لثلاثه عقود نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين هل يمكن اعتبار التحركات
الدبلوماسيه الحاليه تقاربا بين ايران
والولايات
المتحده وتاثير الحركه الدبلوماسيه
الحاليه على القضايا العالقه بين ايران
والغرب لا سيما سوريا والملف
النووي
لقاء جون كيري ومحمد جواد ظريف هو الاعلى
مستوى بين واشنطن وطهران منذ سنوات لذلك
يرى المتفائلون ما جرى اختراقا كبيرا
سيؤدي لتقارب بين البلدين لكن اللقاء لم
ينتج عنه ما يوحي بتغيرات جوهريه في
المواقف لهذا يرى المتشائمون ان رفع سقف
التوقعات لا محل له حاليا الملف النووي
الايراني هو العقبه الرئيسيه بين طهران
والغ
لكن هذا لا يمنع وجود قضايا اخرى ملحه
مختلف عليها اهمها سوريا والامن في
الخليج هل بدا الجليد يذوب اخيرا بين
واشنطن وطهران لاول مره منذ نحو ثلاثه
عقود يعقد لقاء امريكي ايراني بهذا
المستوى لم يكن حدثا عاديا ان يصافحه جون
كيري نظيره جواد محمد ظريف وايضا ان يجلس
جنبا الى جنب حول طاويله محادثات في
نيويورك محادثات بين ايران ومجموعه 5 ئد
واح على هامش اعمال الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده خرج الجميع من القاعات بتصريحات
متفائله وحذره في ان
واحد اجتماع واحد وتغيير في اللهجه التي
لقي ترحيبا لا يجيب على تلك الاسئله
المطروحه هناك عمل كثير يتعين القيام به
اما هدف وزير الخارجيه الايراني الجديد
فهو التاكيد على سلميه البرنامج
لبلاده وفتح صفحه جديده وعد بها الرئيس
حسن روحاني وبعد عشر سنوات من المفاوضات
المارونيه هناك رغبه في تبديد شكوك الغرب
عبر خطوات خلال
عام اجرينا محادثات بناءه كنت اعتقد انني
طموح جدا الى حد السذاجه ولكنني رايت ان
بعض زملائي كانوا اكثر طموحا مني ويريدون
تحقيق ذلك بسرعه حتى نستطيع المضي قدما
حدد تاريخ ال عشر وال 16 عشر من اكتوبر
المقبل موعدا لجوله اخرى من المحادثات بين
مجموعه خم زائد واحد وايران في جنيف في
نيويورك بعث الرئيس حسن الروحاني اكثر من
رساله تحمل تغيرا في لهجه ومنهج سلفه
محمود احمد نجاد التغيير لا يعني استعداد
طهران التخلي عن تخصيب اليورانيوم ولا
الاستمرار في برنامجها الذي تصر على انه
لاغراض سلميه قد تقتنع واشنطن وعواصم
غربيه بسياسه روحان المنفتحه الى حد ما
وفي حدود معينه ولكن هل ستقف اسرائيل
مكتوفه الايدي امام هذا التحول وهل ستقبل
طهران التخلي عن حقها في امتلاك
التكنولوجيا النوويه بينما لا يضغط على
تلابي بنفس القدر لحثها على التخلي عن
ترسانتها النوويه في قلب الشرق الاوسط لا
شك ان روحاني لا يشبه احمد النجاد ولكن
ليس الى درجه تجعل المستحيل ممكنه سياسه
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه دائما
وريثه نظام معقد ذو تاثير واسع في الداخل
والمنطقه
برمتها معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور غسان شبانه رئيس قسم
العلاقات الدوليه بجماعه ماري ماونت
الامريكيه من طهران حسين رويان الباحث في
الشؤون الايرانيه ومن نيورك ادام ايرلي
المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا لو بدانا ب والسفير
ادم ايرلي هل يمكن الحديث عن صفحه جديده
الان بين واشنطن
وطهران نعم نعم اعتقد نستطيع ان نقول ذلك
فما حصل امس بشكل واضح كان امرا كبيرا
ومهما اذ انه هذا لاول مره منذ 30 عاما
يقوم وزير خارجيه امريكي بلقاء مع وزير
خار
ولكني لا اعتقد ان يجب ان نتحمس اكثر ما
ينبغي لهذا الامر
او نتفائل جدا في الموضوع هذا لقاء مهم
ولكن ما ينبغي ان نقوم به هو ان نفصل
الشكل عن المحتوى فالشكل هو اجتماع
دبلوماسيين اما الفحوى فهو ما ناقشه و وهل
استطاع توصل الاتفاق حول ذلك هذا امر يجب
ان ننتظر لنعرف جوابه والامر المهم في
لقاء امس هو ان الوزير كيري
بنفسه عبر عن بعض الحذر في كلامه اذ قال
ان ما سمعته من كلام مهم ولكن علينا ان
ننتظر لنرى هل ان الكلمات الجيده سيتبعها
عمل ملموس وبالتالي فان سمعنا من
المدراء السياسيين
لمجموعه 5+ 1 لانهم سيلتقون ولكي نسمع
تفاصيل طريقه يمكن احتواء و انهاء برنامج
ايران النوي اذا ما وافقت ايران على
القيام بتعاون مثمر وحقيقي مع المجتمع
الدولي للتاكد من برنامجه النوي لا يستخدم
لاغراض عسكريه انذاك اعتقد بامكان نستطيع
القول او الحديث عن صفحه جديده في
العلاقات ولكن الان اقول ما زال سابق
لاوانه مثل هذا الكلام اذا كان مازال
الكثير سيد حسين رييان في في طهران هل
تعتقد بان الامر اصلا ما كان لينطلق لولا
وجود رئيس ايراني
جديد بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني لا شك
ان وجود السيد روحاني
وانتخابه وطرح مقاربه في السياسه الخارجيه
مقاربه جديده في السياسه الخارجيه يعني كل
هذا اتصور هو الاساس لهذه الانطلاقه
الجديده في العلاقات بين ايران وبين
امريكا اهم ميزه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الايرانيه الاخيره التي انتخب انتخب فيها
السيد روحاني هي انها كانت على اساس برامج
سياسيه وليست على اساس شخوص السيد روحاني
اعلن برنامجه منذ البدايه انه يريد ان
يترك سياسه التقابل التي تبعها سلفه يريد
ان يتبع سياسه تعامل هو يحترم الاخر يحترم
هواجس الاخر حتى وان لم تكن مشروعه يحاول
اقناع الاخر بان لا يتعامل بسلبيه مع
ايران كل هذا الكلام دار في الانتخابات
وبعد الانتخابات اعلن السيد روحاني انه
يريد ان يترجم كل هذه الى سياسه ايرانيه
جديده مع الغرب ومع كل دول المنطقه
والعالم من هنا اتصور ان هذه الارضيه
الجديده هي التي اوجدت يعني انطلاقه جديده
في المباحثات بين ايران والمجموعه الغربيه
حول الملف النووي الايراني دكتور شبانا هل
تعتقد الى جانب ما تفضل به ضيفان في في
نيويورك وطهران من حسابات كل بلد هل تعتقد
بان الاساس ربما ان كلا البلدين تعبا من
مواجهه مفتوحه لا افق لها لا طهران
استطاعت ان تقهر الشيطان الاكبر في العالم
ولا امريكا استطاعت ان تقضي على ما تعتبره
عدو في المنطقه او على الاقل بلد مثير
للقلاقل نعم يعني اعتقد هذه القراءه هي
قراءه صحيحه الفجوه ما بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وما ترجوه من ايران
والاقليم بشكل عام والفجوه ما بين ما
ترجوه ايران في الاقليم وبشكل عام هي
كبيره جدا ايران تريد من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان ترفع عنها العقوبات
الاقتصاديه ان تعيدها الى المرحله الاولى
في او الى المراحل القديمه بان تصدر النفط
كيف تشاء تريد لان تكون العمله الايرانيه
ترجع وتعود وتتعافى تريد ايضا من المشروع
النووي الايراني ان يبقى بمعايير ايرانيه
وليس بمعايير دوليه هذه الفجوه الكبيره
اعتقدان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
هذه اللحظه لا تستطيع ان تعطي ايران كل ما
تريد في هذه الفتره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حينما تتحرك باتجاه ايران خطوه
واحده هي ايضا هي ايضا مقابله من الاقليم
الذي تعيش في ايران اي بمعنى الشرق الاوسط
وكل دول الشرق
الاوسط تقول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بان عليك ان تكوني حذره جدا في كيفيه
الحركه التي تتحركين بها لاننا انت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقريبا 8000
ميل عن ايران نحن جيران هذا البلد ونعي ما
هو الهدف الحقيقي من مثل هذه مثل هذه
السياسات اذا ما قرانا في الواشنطن بوست
وما كتبه روحاني روحاني وهذه هذه كتابته
وليس كتابتي قال بانه يريد ان يساعد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في سوريا وفي
البحرين اي بمعنى بان ايران يعني توازن ما
بين ما يجري في البحرين وما يجري في سوريا
يريد بان يكون طرفا ايجابيا في مشاكل
اقليميه كثيره لا اعتقد بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في هذه اللحظه تريد
لايران بان تكون شريك اقليمي فعلي في كل
المواقف وفي كل المجالات ولكن ولكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تريد لايران
ان تسحب نفسها او تناى بنفسها من معظم
الملفات التي اقحمت نفسها فيها ملف حماس
ملف حزب الله ملف سوريا ملف العراق الملف
النووي اذا ما فعلت ذلك ايران في هذه
الفتره اعتقد بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سوف تبدا بالنظر الى ايران على
انها طرف ايجابي في الاقليم وفي المنطقه ل
يعني لحيث للحظه التي سوف يتحقق فيها ذلك
لا اعتقد بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
سوف تهرع الى ان تسلم او تستسلم لايران
على اي حد ولكن هي لم تهرع سيد ادم ارلي
ولكن هل هل ما يجري الان من بدايه صفحه
جديده ربما تكون السياسه الامريكيه هي
الاكثر حرصا عليه لان عندما نرى السيد
كيري كيف يعالج الملف السوري كيف يعالج
المفاوضات بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
هو نفسه الان يتوجه لما لا لمحاوله تليين
العلاقات مع
طهران
كلا كلا لا اعتقد ذلك واعتقد هناك
نقطتان اشار اليه السيد حسن والدكتور غسان
ايضا اود ان اكد على عليها في جوابي على
سؤالك
اولا ان الجميع يتحدث عن الشخصيات شخصيه
الرئيس روحاني شخصيه جون كيري ولكن الامر
لا يتعلق بالشخصيات بل يتعلق
بالسياسات
وان الشخصيات قد تتغير
روحاني ذو جاذبيه اكثر من سابقه اكثر وديه
من احمدي نجاد ولكن السؤال هو هل تغيرت
سياساته والدكتور غسان
قال دعونا نكون حذرين هنا وانا اتفق معه
تماما انه من المهم جدا ان تذكر
اولا ان الرئيس روحاني ليس القائد الاعلى
لايران ذلك الدور هو علي خام ان يقوم بذلك
المرشد الاعلى وبناء على الدستور الايراني
وبناء على ولايه الحكيم اؤكد لكم ان
الرئيس روحاني لا يقوم باي شيء دون
التخويل من المرشد الاعلى وهذا ينطبق على
ما قام فيه في نيويورك و ايضا سينطبق على
المفاوضات البرنامج النووي وايضا سينطبق
على اي اي اتفاق في المستقبل وبالتالي
الامر لا يتعلق بشخصيات بل بسياسات
وبالمؤسسات التي تحكم ايران النقطه
الاخيره وكما قال الدكتور
غسان كل شيء في شرق اوت مرتبط شيء بعضه
ببعض لا يمكن ان نعزل بلد وقضيه ما عن
الاخرى او الاخر وبالتالي لا نستطيع
الحديث عن مناقشات ومفاوضات حول الملف
النووي بمعزل
عما يحصل في سوريا وعما يحصل في العراق
وفي في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وفي مصر لان
ايران هي قوه كبرى في المنطقه بعدد سكانها
باقتصادها تاريخها وثقافتها وستؤدي دورا
في المنطقه واعتقد ان ما ينبغي ان نقوم
بالولايات المتحده وانه شركاء معنا بهو ان
نكون حذرين وان نتذكر هو ان الدور الذي
تلعبه ايران في كل المناطق هل هو دور
ايجابي ام سلبي انا كنت السفير الامريكي
في البحرين منذ عام 2007 الى
2011 و ضيفكم تحدث عن البحرين وشار اليها
واستطيع اقول لكم الان انه دون اي شك او
اي صفه من الصفات استطيع القول ان الدور
اللي تقوم به ايران في البحرين هو دور
سلبي الدور اللي يقومون فيه في
الخليج لا ينظر اليه من قبل كثيرين في
الخليج على انه تصرف
دوله وديه او مسالمه وبالتالي دعونا ان لا
نتحمس و ننجرف
حول الاعمال الرائعه او الموقف الذي
شاهدناه في نيويورك قبل في خمسه ايام من
قبل روحاني ذلك ان خمسه ايام من الزمن لا
تلغي عقود من السلوك السيء وان التهديدات
والاعتداءات التي حصلت كلها لا لا تلغيها
خمسه ايام ال نعم على كل كل هذه الملاحظات
والتحفظات الخاصه بايران سنحمل الى ضيفنا
في طهران مباشره بعد الفاصل حيث سنتطرق
الى الى اي مدى العلاقه بين ايران والغرب
خاصه في ملفات سوريا واامن في الخليج يمكن
ان تتاثر بشكل او باخر لهذه العلاقات
الجديده ربما بين طهران وواشنطن لنا عوده
نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
الحلقه التي نناقش فيها مستقبل العلاقات
الامريكيه الايرانيه في ضوء لقاء كري
وظريف سيد حسين نوريان في في طهران كل هذه
الماخذ التي تحدث عنها السيد ادم ايرلي
بالطبع لم يقع تبديدها الى حد الان كيف
يمكن ربما الشروع في علاقات نوعا ما جديده
تستطيع فيها ايران ان تحد من هذه المخاوف
فيما يتعلق بهذه
الملفات يعني اتصور ان من غير المطروح
مسلم ايران لما تطلبه امريكا والعكس صحيح
انه امريكا ايضا لا من ما تطالب به ايران
يعني ايران الان
هي للاسف الشديد
للاسفل
مشتركه هناك مساحات مشتركه يعني تطرح
مساله التعاون بينهما امريكا تريد ان
تغادر افغانستان امن الخليج المساله
السوريه والكثير من الملفات الاقليميه
الاخرى كل هذه يمكن ان تكون يعني
المساحات المشتركه هي نقطه الانطلاق
للتفاهم بين هذين
اي الطرفين هذا لا يعني يعني ان يكون
الطرفان متطابقان بالكامل لا لان الرؤيه
بين البلدين مختلف ولكن اتصور المساحه
المشتركه الان هي كبيره لدرجه تسمح
بالتعاون والتفاهم فيما بينهما خدمه
لمصلحه البلدين ومصلحه المنطقه ولكن هذه
المساحات المشتركه سيد روران هل هل ربما
تعني ان طهران مستعده لترضيه واشنطن من
جيب غير
اكثر مما ستحاول ان ترضيها في ملفها
النووي لا تصور ان ايران يعني تحاول من
خلال الدفاع عن مصالحها ومصالح دول
المنطقه ان تتعامل مع الغرب يعني في الملف
النووي الايراني اعلن السيد روحاني والسيد
ظريف وزير الخارجيه ايضا انها تحاول اقناع
الطرف الاخر رفع هواجسه
والقبول بضمان
يعني تؤكد سلميه البرنامج انه الايراني
هذا يعني ان ايران تريد ان يعني تعطي
ضمانات من منها وليس من دول المنطقه ولكن
في الملفات الاقليميه نعم هناك
يعني امن اقليمي وامن وطني تتداخل فيه و
يعني تخلق معادله معقده هنالك تختلف
المساله بين ايران
وامريكا في هذه الحاله دت دكتور شبانه
يعني مثلا الملف السوري كانت واشنطن لديها
فيتو على حضور طهران لجنيف اثنين الان
ربما الاجواء تسمح بان لا تمانع لا احد
تحدث في هذا الموضوع على كل حد الان نعم
يعني لا اعتقد بان الاجواء تسمح لهذه
الدرجه لماذا لانه اذا ما نظرنا الى
الطاقم الذي اعده الرئيس روحاني ليمثله
يعني في الخارج جواد ظريف هو انسان ممتاز
جدا بالنسبه للعلاقات الدوليه كوزير
خارجيه ولكن في الداخل درسه في امريكا
درسه في امريكا يتكلم عده لغات اجنبيه
ولكن في الداخل علي شمخاني علي شمخاني هو
يعني الى اليمين من خامنائي وهو رئيس
الامن القومي الامري الايراني في هذه
اللحظه لذلك يعني روحاني يتكلم الى الغرب
بلسان ظريف ويتكلم الى الايرانيين بلسان
شمخاني شمخاني هو معروف عنه انه احد
المتشددين او احد اكثر المتشددين بالنسبه
للقضايا الاقليميه هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
ثانيه يعني لواء القدس والحرس الثوري هم
الذين يديرون الملف السوري ولا اعتقد بان
روحاني يستطيع او بامكانه ان يعني ان يقرب
او ان يقترب من مثل هذا من مثل هذا هكذا
ملف لذلك اعتقد بان يعني ايدي روحاني
طائله بالنسبه لهذه المواضيع لذلك اعتقد
بان الفجوه كبيره جدا ما بين ما تريده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في الملف
السوري وما تريده او ما يريده روحاني في
هذه اللحظه لكن الاقتراب الملف السوري
دكتور لا يعني بالضروره ان ان طهران
مستعده للتخلي عن بشار الاسد ولكنها
مستعده ربما ان تثبت لواشنطن انها قادره
على الضغط على بشار الاسد لقبول ب باشياء
قد تكون مؤلمه روحاني روحاني بما انه يعني
اعترف بان هناك استعمال للكيماوي بدا بلغه
جديده جدا عن نظيره احمد دي نجات ولكن في
نفس الوقت هل يستطيع روحاني ان يطلب من
قوات القدس ومن الحرث الثوري ان يسحب
الجيش الايراني او الميليشيات الايران
التي تقاتل الى جنب الاسد داخل سوريا هذا
سؤال مهم هل يستطيع ايضا اقناع حزب الله
بالانسحاب ايضا من سوريا هذا شيء ايضا مهم
هل يستطيع ان يقنع حزب الله العراقي
للانسحاب من سوريا هذا ايضا شيء مهم جدا
لذلك يعني كل هذه الملفات هي في ايد لواء
لواء القدس والحرس الثوري الايراني ما ما
يمكن ما يمكن لروحاني ان يفعل في هذه
الملفات التي تعتبر شائكه جدا بالنسبه
للملف السوري هل بي اس طاعته ان يفعل كل
ما يريده منه الغرب يعني لا احد يقول له
فيتو على الاسد او صوت الى الاسد هذا يعني
شيء ل لروحاني الحق فيه ولكن ادخال
ميليشيا ودعم ميليشيا اخرى لتتدخل في
الشان السوري اعتقد بان هذا سؤال جدا يجب
الاجابه عليه ويجب الاجابه عليه بصوره
ايجابيه وليس سلبيه نعم هناك ايضا لاعبون
اقليمي سفير ادم ايرلي حليفكم اسرائيل
وحليفهم الاخر دول الخليج بالتاكيد دول
الخليج العربيه لن تنظر بارتياح لهذه
الاجواء الجديده وبدايه غزل ربما بين
واشنطن و وطهران كيف ستتعافى واشنطن مع
ذلك اعتقد ان واشنطن ينبغي ان تكون واضحه
في موقعها والرئيس هو يجب ان يكون واضحا
جدا
والواقع وقد كتبنا عن ذلك في الصحف قرانا
عن ذلك في الصحف الامريكيه الرئيس اوباما
اوضح موقف الولايات المتحده ومع من تقف
الولايات المتحده اعتقد انه من المفهوم ان
شركائنا في دول مجلس التعاون الخليج و
يشعرون بقلق قلق ازاء هذه التطورات وطبعا
واضح من واضح انهم قلقون بان الولايات
المتحده ان قوه
التزام الولايات المتحده ااهم قد ضعف
نتيجه هذا الانفتاح الجديد او هذا التسخين
الظاهري مع في العلاقات مع طهران اعتقد ان
الرئيس اوباما وادارته ان
يكونوا حذرين في التوضيح بشكل لا شك فيه
بان امريكا تقف الى جانب اصدقائها في مجل
دول الخليج وتدافع عن اصدقائها في دول
مجلس التعاون الخليجي وان اي شيء تقون
ولايه المتحده لن يكون على حساب علاقاتنا
على علاقاتنا الاستراتيجيه وشركاء
الاستراتيجيين في دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي لانه بصراحه اذا اردنا ان نراهن
من هو الفائز لو كان سباق خيل مثلا او
سباق هجن واردت ان نحن على الحصان الذي
سيكون في المركز الاول وسيبقى معك خلال
الفتره كلها فهم دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي لا تراهن على الحصان الجميل الذي
قد قد يكون اجمل من غيره
يركض بشكل جميل
ولكن وضعوا كل مراهنات واموالكم على
الحصان الذي سيحقق الفوز ويبقى معك في كل
السباقات وهذا بعني بذلك دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وبالتالي على اداره
اوباما ان تطمئن
حلفائها باننا معهم وان اي شيء نقوم به لن
يعرض الخطر علاقاتنا والتزاماتنا بامنه
ولكن ه هل يمكن هل يمكن ايضا لطهران ان ان
تطمئن غيرها اذا سالنا سيد حسين روران في
نهايه هذه الحلقه هل هل يمكن لطهران ان ان
تكون بين قوسين اكثر جديه في الوصول الى
اتفاق فيما يتعلق بالسلاح النووي خلال
بضعه اشهر كما تم الحديث من قبل سيد ظريف
والرئيس
روحاني يعني اولا في حل ازمه الملف النووي
الايراني هناك اختلاف في وجهات النظر هناك
تراكم 35 عاما من السلبيه بين البلدين
البعض يرى انه يمكن تحديد اطار زمني
وبعد ذلك تعريف ما يجب ان ي يقوم به
الطرفان او ان تكون هناك خطوه بخطوه وهذا
يمكن ان تاخذ فتره زمنيه اكبر ولكن اتصور
ان ايران الان تراهن على مسالتين
اولا الحوار مع الغرب مساله والحوار
الاقليمي ايضا مطروح كاولو اولى للسيد
روحان
وال الحوار مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وباقي دول المنطقه ستكون ضمن اولويات
السيد روحاني من هنا اتصور ان ايران لا
تريد ان تتعامل مع الغرب على حساب المنطقه
بل ان تريد ان يعني تقلل من الفوارق وال
التقابلات القائمه على المستوى الاقليمي
والدولي شكرا جزيلا لك سيد حسين روان
الباحث في الشؤون الايرانيه من طهران شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا من نيويورك السفير ادم اورلي
المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
من
واشنطن و عفوا من نيويورك ليس من واشنطن
وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا هنا في الاستديو
الدكتور غسان شبانه رئيس قسم العلاقات
الدوليه بجماعه ماري ماونت الامريكيه دمتم
في رعايه الله والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ن